[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENI FISHER: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jeni.
I'm from the Apps Partnerships
team here at Google Play.
So on a daily basis, I
speak to app developers
about their challenges
and their goals.
They tell me that they're trying
to get more users to subscribe.
They're trying to get more
users to discover features
within their apps.
The developers I talk
to, as well as everyone
else in this room,
you optimize products
in order to better influence
how your users behave.
And so for me, it
really makes sense
that if you want to better
optimize for user behavior,
we should understand a bit
more about behavioral insights.
It just makes complete sense.
So later on, you're
going to hear from Sami,
who's the CEO of The Fabulous.
And The Fabulous is an
app that helps people
build better daily habits.
He'll share how they
saw remarkable growth
in user retention as
a result of applying
behavioral economic
principles to the app.
So in my job as Apps
Business Development Manager,
I've spent the last
year immersing myself
in the fields of behavioral
economics, gamification,
and product psychology.
And I'm sure people in this room
as well as on the live stream
recognize quite a few of the
books on this virtual bookshelf
here.
So we have books like
"Nudge," "Hooked,"
"Predictably Irrational."
And there are so
many great principles
within all of these books
that app developers can be
applying to their apps today.
And so you don't have to
be a behavioral scientist
to understand what
your users want.
You just need to
get a feel for some
of the principles
in these books.
Start experimenting, and
see what works for you.
So today's session will
really act as a reminder,
because I'm sure a lot
of you are applying
similar principles already.
And what I'm going to
be sharing with you
are ways that you can address
your users' needs better
in ways that save
yourselves time and money.
So to make this session as
actionable as possible for you,
what I want you to do is to keep
in mind one key user behavior
that you're trying to
optimize in your own app.
This could be purchasing
a subscription,
inviting a friend to the app,
or perhaps getting more people
to return to your app after
that initial onboarding phase.
So hopefully everyone here
has that behavior in mind.
So keep it in mind throughout
the rest of the session.
So now, what I want
to do is introduce you
to three steps inspired
by behavioral insights
that you can follow to make
this particular desired action
a reality.
Many companies tend to
focus on step three, which
is all about trying to boost
user motivation, when actually,
I think time and money could
be better spent by focusing
on step one, which
is identifying
the barriers in the first place.
And so when I talked
about step three then,
it's about often developers
focus on costly reward schemes
and loyalty schemes.
So instead, let's
start with step one,
simplifying the behavior.
So every decision we make
requires overcoming barriers
of some kind.
Let's think about everyone
in this room today.
The fact that you've
decided to attend I/O,
perhaps you had to overcome
huge distances to get here.
You had to debate over
whether the cost of the ticket
was worth the price.
Maybe you had loads
of other commitments
that you had to also
think about committing to,
but instead you are here today.
So why haven't
more users carried
out that one specific
behavior that you've
identified a few moments ago?
Again, let's think about it.
It could be it takes
too much time for them
to complete that action.
Perhaps the purchase
involved is too costly,
or choosing to do it
among other choices
just requires too
much mental effort.
And so we can simplify
this by identifying
these types of barriers to
behavior and removing them.
So the food delivery
app, Just Eat,
knew that they would get more
successful repeat transactions
if their users save payment
details during the checkout
flow.
Now, via Google Analytics, they
identified that many users just
weren't doing this.
And while this data
tells us the what,
it doesn't necessarily
tell you the why.
It doesn't tell you why
users weren't doing this.
So what they had
to do was actually
conduct usability tests.
And by taking this
approach, they
found out that many users had
certain emotions that you just
can't identify in data.
For example, some
users were concerned
about the security
of digital payments,
while others simply
didn't want to take
that extra step of clicking
Save Payment Details.
So after identifying
these barriers,
Just Eat simplified the act
of saving the payment details
by firstly making
the last used card
the default payment option
for any future transaction.
And this is really
important here,
because defaults are
extremely powerful.
We tend to follow the
path of least resistance.
So when defaults
make sense, they're
a really great way of
overcoming that barrier to act.
Secondly, Just Eat
prioritized partnerships
with trusted payment providers
to reduce security concerns
in those users.
And again, even if
you're not currently
running usability
sessions, the Play console
offers some really great
tools to help you identify
your users' pain points.
For example, you can
analyze real user reviews
with the topics and
benchmarks analysis features.
So decision making is impacted
by the number of choices
offered, which is something Sami
will talk about a bit later on
and how they tackled
that in The Fabulous.
But it's also impacted
by how those choices are
presented to the user.
So now, I want you
just to take a look
and glance at this upsell flow
from the recipe app, Simple
Feast.
So they're offering the users
three choices, the monthly,
the yearly, and the forever.
So I'd love to get a show
of hands here in this room.
Who thinks they're
trying to get more people
to purchase the monthly plan?
No hands.
What about the yearly plan?
It's pretty unanimous.
And how about the forever plan?
OK, there's a few hands there.
So the answer is
the yearly plan,
because this is
actually the best value
plan for their users.
And what they did
was they applied
four different behavioral
concepts in order
to aid this decision making.
So firstly, they
leveraged social proofing.
This is seen across so
many different apps now.
What's most popular?
What are most of the
other users doing?
And this type of information
is really great for users
when they're uncertain
in any way about what
they need to do next.
Secondly, they've called
out the yearly plan
in a very different color.
So really helping to
emphasize the annual plan
as their preferred choice.
Thirdly, for the
yearly plan, they've
framed that price
at a monthly price.
This is a more digestible
and easy way for us
to understand what
is the actual cost,
and it helps minimize that
barrier of the perceived
cost to the user.
And lastly, the introduction
of the forever plan--
while some users may be
straight away willing to pay
that much money, it's
actually strategically
added there to help make
the yearly plan seem
more reasonably priced.
This is often known
as the decoy effect.
And so overall, these four
different techniques really
help to simplify that
decision for the user,
and make sure that it's more
likely that they're going
to choose the yearly plan.
And that's actually what
the Simple Feast app saw.
So we've covered some tactics
to simplify the behavior.
You've identified the barriers.
And so what we're
going to do now
is to move on to step
two or three, which
is all about triggers.
So it's important to place
powerful and actionable
triggers at relevant moments
in front of engaged users.
These triggers could be in-app
messages, email campaigns,
or, of course, the hugely
popular push notification.
And I'm sure everyone
here would love
to achieve a 300% uplift in
push notification open rates.
So let's find out now how the
language learning app busuu
achieved this.
busuu applied the
behavioral designer,
Nir Eyal's "Hooked" model
to their push reengagement
campaigns.
The first step in the
model is this trigger.
And if you take a look,
the push notification
serves as the external trigger--
something that's
prompted by the developer
to get the attention
of the user.
Now, what's important here
is that this external trigger
aligns with the user's
internal trigger of curiosity.
It's messaged as a question.
It gets them
thinking about a word
that they've already
learned, and as well
as this, an important
tactic that busuu uses,
is they never send the
same messaging twice.
And I'm sure many
of you here tend
to get the same daily
reminders, the same prompts,
every single day.
And you get bored
of it, and you tend
to swipe it away without
actually reading it.
So the importance of variable
messaging is crucial.
So step two-- the
user takes action,
and then clicks through
to complete the quiz.
And hopefully, they answer
the question correctly.
If they do, the third
step is the reward.
And so they receive
a well-done message--
a simple reward for improving
their language learning skills.
And so all of these
different steps
together lead to
that investment,
because this model helps them
increase their memory strength.
And this further aligns the
app to their core goal as well.
Even better, this investment
increases the chances
of the user engaging with the
app of their own prerogative
without needing that developer
trigger to remind them
to reengage with the busuu app.
So for more best practices
on push notifications
and other tools for success,
don't miss this upcoming talk
by my colleagues Niko and Jeena
on this stage at 1:30 PM today.
So, where appropriate,
another strategy
to ensure your triggers are as
powerful as they can possibly
be is scarcity.
Now, when something is available
in limited time or limited
quantities, we're
prone to value it
more because we have a
fear of missing out on it.
And so go back that behavior
you identified earlier.
What can be made scarce that can
make more users likely to take
that decision to act?
So I'm going to show you an
example now of how the health
and lifestyle app Lifesum
wanted to increase
the number of subscriptions
that users purchased on day one
throughout the onboarding flow.
So what they did was they
offered a starter kit that
was messaged as "today only."
Now, this was available.
It was an exclusive
starter kit, and it
was only available to people
who subscribed at that moment.
And this add-on increased
subscription conversion by 15%.
So it's a hugely
powerful way of helping
to make people act sooner.
So we've thought about how we
can simplify the behavior, how
we can make sure our triggers
are in the right places
and are as powerful and
persuasive as they can possibly
be.
So our final step is to
ensure that our users
are motivated and really want
to take the desired action.
This is one of the hardest
elements to influence,
and I would encourage focusing
on boosting motivation
for behaviors where users maybe
aren't already sufficiently
engaged with the app.
So before we dig deeper
into motivation, let's
just discuss the
fact that there are
two broad types of motivation
that we should think about.
So there's intrinsic
motivation, where
the act of doing something
itself is the reward.
And then there's
extrinsic motivation.
So you can think about this
in terms of maybe offering
incentives.
If someone's doing
something just
to get the resulting
benefit out of the outcome,
that is something that
extrinsically motivates us.
So games are in many ways the
ultimate motivational product.
After all, many people here--
and I'm sure on the live stream
as well-- you've all spent
hours of your lives playing
with these games, especially
when they're successfully
engaging you.
So I'm sure many people
here today as well
understand that there's
a lot of research
out there about why
games are so powerful.
And it goes back to
this idea that it's
creating this genuine
level of engagement
when it taps into our
intrinsic motivations.
So again, the act of playing
the game is the reward itself.
So what I'm going to do
now is share with you
a four-step framework
for intrinsic motivation.
It's essentially
a summary of two
different motivational
theories, and this was created--
it's called the RAMP framework.
It was created by
Andrzej Marczewski.
And this will really
help any app developers
who are thinking about
different techniques that
can help foster intrinsic
motivation within their app.
So relatedness is the first
step of the RAMP framework.
Relatedness is all about
building social connections,
feeling part of a community,
and belonging to a community
as well.
An example in a game
would be collaborating
with real and virtual friends
to complete a mission.
The second step in the
RAMP framework is autonomy.
So this is all about making
sure your users have the freedom
to make their own
choices and decisions,
and not feel like someone else
is controlling them in any way.
An example in a game would be
exploring a virtual universe
or customizing an avatar
to your exact liking.
The third step is mastery.
So mastery is this driver in
everyone, all of us, to keep
progressing, keep
improving our skills.
And a gamer might
spend hours perfecting
their particular skills in
order to level up or complete
a mission.
And the last step in
ramping up your users
to be motivated to act
is this idea of purpose.
So this is the drive
to add value to a cause
larger than ourselves.
So when in doubt,
adopting techniques that
tap into your users' needs, one
of these four core or intrinsic
motivations, is going to be
a great way of ensuring that.
So we're now going to dig
into some examples of how
app developers are
tapping into these four
intrinsic motivations.
And also look out for
a future blog post
on the Google Play Dev
"Medium" publication
where I'll be deep diving
into this in a bit more detail
as well.
So game elements in
and of themselves
do not create engagement.
But when these elements
appeal to what intrinsically
motivates us, they have a
better chance of creating that.
And so I want to now talk
you through Catch It English.
This is a language learning app.
They've obsessed over the use
of game elements within the app,
and you can see they've had
some really great success.
They have a seven-day
retention rate
of 45%, which is on
a par with RPG games.
And I'm sure many app
developers in this room
would love to have a
retention of almost 45%.
So let's now look at the two
techniques that they've used,
and the intrinsic motivations
that these tap into.
So within the app, they have
study group functionality.
These study groups
collaborate together
to help each other
learn the language,
and this taps into our
desire for relatedness--
so to have connections
and to support others.
Now, an interesting
twist here is
that the study groups
together can then
compete with each other.
And again, competition
on a leader board--
that's a really classic
way of trying to tap
into our desire for mastery.
We want to keep
improving and get better,
and, ideally, be
better than our peers.
So as well as this,
the app itself
has some really exciting
visual and audio cues.
And they're created
in such a way
that they help
reinforce progress
as the user is going through
the app and learning English.
So various studies suggest that
altruistic behavior releases
endorphins, also known
as the helper's high.
So giving your users
the opportunity
to help others, no
matter how indirectly,
can really tap into
their drive for purpose.
The yoga app,
Yogaia, really cares
about getting more
users to attend
their online live classes.
And so what they did
was they ran an A/B test
with this in-app messaging here.
And essentially, what
they're asking is,
if you attend this
live class, we
are going to donate
money to charity.
And in fact, this actually
gave them a 9% uplift
in class attendance.
And also, goal setting goes
hand-in-hand with our desire
for mastery.
And I'm sure many
app developers here
are helping their
users reach new goals.
And so I'm going to now talk
through two different examples
of app developers who are using
these types of game elements
and seeing great success
in terms of user retention.
So the hiking app, ViewRanger--
they have allowed users to
sign up for in-app challenges
to hike more, to cycle more.
And when they did some analysis,
the users that had signed up
for these challenges were
actually four times as active
within the ViewRanger app
than those who hadn't.
There's also the Smoke Free app.
Now, they did an
A/B test offering
50% of users daily missions, and
the other 50% didn't get access
to any daily missions.
And what's really
amazing here is
that the users who saw the
daily missions within the app
were twice as likely
to quit smoking
after three months, so really
powerful motivational stuff
there.
And so I want to
take a step back now.
Think back to that user behavior
you had identified earlier.
Are you using rewards to
effectively drive this?
I'm going to now share with
you a hierarchy of rewards.
This is devised by the
gamification consultant,
Gabe Zichermann.
And it helps to suggest the
order of rewards and how costly
they are or how powerful
they are at driving
loyalty and retention.
And so you can see at the
very bottom of this is stuff.
Stuff is things like cash,
gift cards, freebies.
So why is this the least
powerful when so many of us
offer discounts and freebies
to try and incentivize people?
And one of the reasons
could be that they neglect
what genuinely motivates us.
If you go back to the idea
of the RAMP framework,
relatedness, autonomy,
mastery, purpose--
getting these one-time
rewards doesn't necessarily
tap into that long term.
And again, while
money and cash can
be sufficient to drive
short term behavior change,
it can very quickly lose its
power because people quickly
come to expect the
reward every time they
take that particular action.
And often, you have to give
more to get them to be motivated
to act the second time.
So what I would
suggest from this slide
is rewarding your users with
more meaningful rewards.
So if we look at
status, how can you
make your most engaged
users feel like VIPs?
What are the different
perks that they can
get that other users might not?
And then if we
think about access,
what are the features
within your app that
maybe are exclusively
accessible to certain users?
And that could be
a more powerful way
of engaging them
and actually keeping
them retained for longer.
So I'm sure many of you in the
audience are game developers.
And you know that game
elements, as I said before,
do not in and of themselves
create engagement.
So I wanted to leave you
with a cautionary tale.
So points and badges,
they're great.
However, if they
don't genuinely map
to what really
motivates your users,
and if they don't symbolize
hard-earned achievements,
then they're not going to
sufficiently motivate users.
And if anything, what they
might actually do is make
them feel like they're being
bribed to act in some way.
And this can lead
to user frustration.
So take a look at this
Play Store app rating
of a particular developer.
When they implemented
a points-based system,
they quickly saw a dramatic
decrease in the average rating.
Because even though
they had implemented
the elements themselves, they
hadn't necessarily connected it
to what motivated those users.
So you've thought of
the behavior change you
wanted to see in your users.
We've talked about how you
can simplify the behavior, how
you can trigger,
and then also, how
you can connect that
behavior to something
they find intrinsically
rewarding.
So I'm now going to
hand over to Sami,
who will reveal how The
Fabulous app successfully
drives behavior change
not just within the app,
but also within their
users' everyday lives.
Thank you.
SAMI BEN HASSINE: Thanks, Jeni.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everyone So I'm the
co-founder and CEO of Fabulous.
Fabulous is an app that helps
you build healthy routines
into your life.
We are incubated at Duke
University and the Center
for Advanced Hindsight, which
is a lab led by Dan Ariely,
professor of behavior economics,
and the author of the book
"Predictably Irrational."
So I'd like to frame
this presentation
around this framework
that you have developed
at the lab that
could help you make
better decisions in your app.
So first of all, think
about the behavior.
What's the exact behavior that
you want your user to achieve?
Then think about the barriers.
What are the elements that
could prevent your user
from achieving this behavior?
And finally, think
about the benefits.
What do I gain once I
achieve that behavior?
So let's quickly jump
into one example.
This is the first
screen that you
used to get when
you opened Fabulous.
And as you can see,
it looks pretty good.
Let's get Fabulous.
What's your most important
health goal right now?
Then you can choose to feel
more energized, to sleep better.
Looks pretty well.
But there is one big
problem with this screen.
I'll give you just a few
seconds to think it out.
So the problem with the
screen was the question
that we were asking.
What's your most important
health goal right now?
So when users read this, they
started asking themselves
all sorts of questions.
Can I make the wrong choice?
Can I change my opinion later?
What if I want to
change my goal?
So one simple change that
we did is just asking them
which goal would you
like to start with.
And now, we are giving
them the permission
to change their minds later.
And this has uplifted the
onboarding completion rate
by 15%.
So we wanted to go
even further than this,
and we started limiting
the options as well,
like providing them
with a default option.
And this again has increased
the retention on day one.
So here's a tip.
Your user is using
your app, and he's
asking himself all sorts
of questions all the time.
Can I put my credit
card information?
Is it secure enough?
So try to answer all these
questions for the user.
Try always to provide the
answer, so that the user
doesn't feel frustrated.
Because otherwise, if
he starts asking himself
too many questions, he
will just close the app.
So to tell you a little
bit about Fabulous.
In Fabulous, we aim to help
you build a morning routine.
And in our opinion, this
is a good morning routine.
You wake up.
You drink water.
You exercise a little bit,
and then for some people,
you would eat a great breakfast.
In order to get you to do this,
this is how we used to do it.
This was the old onboarding.
So you would get
to the screen where
you have all these
habits, and then
everything else is
in and out, and you
need to tap on Drink Water.
So we were forcing
the users to do this.
And I have to tell
you, they were really
frustrated about this.
They thought that we
were forcing them.
They even sent us
this kind of email.
You betrayed my trust when I
had great expectations for you.
Well, how can we solve this?
Let's go back to these
ideas of behavior economics.
Let's first start
with the behavior.
What's the behavior that
you are trying to achieve?
Feeling more energized--
well, that's not the behavior,
actually.
That's the outcome.
If you want to think
about the behavior,
think about the exact steps
that your user needs to take.
In our case, it's waking
up in the morning,
reaching out to my
bottle of water,
and then drinking water, and
taking some time to feel great.
The behavior is not the outcome.
And then let's get to the
second step, the barriers.
I want to drink water,
or I don't want.
What are the barriers?
So we conducted a user survey.
And these were the
three main obstacles.
I'm not convinced that
I need to drink water.
I want to drink water, but
I don't have water at reach.
Or I'm just not very committed.
Let's try to solve this.
This is the new onboarding.
The new onboarding, instead
of asking you to drink water,
we start by asking
you a few questions.
Do you want to build a habit
of exercising in the morning?
Some people might say yes.
Some people might say no.
Then, do you want to
build the habit of eating
great breakfast in the morning?
Same, some people might say yes.
Some people might say no.
And then we ask you the most
important question for us.
Do you want to drink
water in the morning?
So this seems very easy related
to the three other goals.
It's just drinking water.
So even if I said no to
the two other questions,
I'm going to say yes.
Almost 99% of the
people are going
to say yes, I want to
drink water in the morning.
And in this case, it was
your choice, actually.
It was something that
you choose to do.
It's not us forcing this on you.
Now, let's think about
the second barrier.
I'm not very committed.
I don't feel very
committed to this.
Well, what you can
do in this case
is using what we call in
behavior clinics implementation
intention, which is
simply asking the user.
Do you commit to
drink water tomorrow?
And you can even
enhance this effect
by using what we
call active choice.
Active choice means
that you're going
to reframe the yes question
as something very positive
for your user, like--
I want to drink water and
feel great about myself.
And then you frame the
negative answer as something
not that good.
I don't want to drink water.
I don't care about my health.
So here's another way in
which you can do this.
As you know, we're all
trying to get our users
to invite their friends.
And generally, we
would ask them.
Please invite your
friends to our app.
That's something really great.
It will make us happy.
But generally, users
will just turn away.
So another way of doing
this is, first of all,
by stating the benefits.
If you invite your
friends to Fabulous,
you are much more likely
to complete your habits.
And then second of all,
let's use the active choice.
So here we provide them
with three choices.
Two of them are positive.
One is negative.
One of them is--
I'd like to invite my friend
to join me on this journey.
I want to invite my friend to
monitor me on this journey.
And then the third choice is--
I'll do it on my own.
It's a little bit
negative, actually.
So always answer this
question for the user.
What is in it for me?
What do I gain out
of doing this action?
Always provide the benefits.
Go through the copy of your
app, and state everything
as benefits, not as goals,
not as objectives, but as
benefits for the final user.
Now, here's a bonus one.
You can get your user
to commit even more
by using what we call a
commitment contract, which
is simply asking the
user to commit to a place
and time in which they are
more likely to accomplish
that behavior.
And then you would ask them
to sign up with their name.
This is called the
commitment contract.
Now, let's think about
the next barrier.
Well, I want to drink
water, but I just
don't have water at reach.
If you think about
your users, they
are much more likely
to commit to your app
when they first opened the
app or when they have just
completed one milestone.
So this is the best
time for you to ask
for even more engagement.
In our case, after they commit,
we're going to ask them--
would you like us to
send a reminder tonight
so that you put your water
bottle by your bedside?
This is beneficial
for the users.
So they are really
likely to say yes.
If you are a finance app,
this could be the right moment
to ask them to set
up automatic saving.
If you are Google Photo,
this is the right time
to ask for auto backup
of your pictures.
So think about one
action in your app
that could really lead
to much more engagement.
Think about ways to
make it automated,
and then ask the user to
commit to this on high points,
either on the onboarding or
just after they successfully
completed the milestone
within your app.
So now lets get to the third
part, the benefits part.
What do I gain out
of doing all of this?
Well, this is an interesting
one, because, of course,
it's changing from
one app to the next.
If you are a weight loss app,
it's very easy for the user
to know that they
have gained something.
They will just weigh
themselves one week in,
and they would see if this
has been beneficial or no.
So in the case of Fabulous,
since we didn't have that,
we thought about this idea.
So each time that you
complete your habits,
we are going to ask you to
take some time to celebrate,
to feel good about yourself.
You need something tangible
to provide for the user
after a few days of
usage so that they
understand that they are gaining
something out of your app.
And here is a good
way to think about it.
Let's suppose that
they keep using
your app for a few months.
How's this going to
transform my life?
Now, take all these
benefits and make
them immediate and salient.
Tell the user-- this
is what you are gaining
on every step of the way.
So here it is.
We have now applied the three
tenets of behavior economics.
First of all, we started
with the outcome.
We want the user to
feel more energized,
and from there, we got the exact
behavior that we need to apply.
I want to wake up and reach
out to my bottle of water.
And then we conducted
a user survey
to know about the barriers.
And some people are
not committed enough.
In this case, we used what
we call the implementation
intention in order to
get them to commit.
Some people didn't
have water at reach.
So we used the
active choice idea
in order to get us to send
them a gentle reminder
that same night for
them to put a water
bottle by their bedside.
And then we have provided
them with a tangible benefit
by asking them to
celebrate for a few minutes
their achievements.
Hope this has been useful.
Thanks, and back to Jeni.
JENI FISHER: Thank
you very much.
So I want just to recap.
If you go back to
that one key behavior
you identified at the
beginning of this talk,
I really hope that you
found something inspiring
from both mine and
Sami's session,
and that you already
have great ideas
of how you are going
to implement these
into your own app.
And so once you
have done that, I'd
love it if you could
share with us your app
techniques via Twitter using
the hashtag #appengagement
and to keep in touch with us
about Google Play in general
as well.
Please stay up to date
via these links here.
And as I've mentioned before,
the medium.com/googleplaydev is
another great resource
for best practices.
So I hope you really
enjoyed today's session.
Thank you so much for listening,
and if you have any questions,
please go ahead and
step up to the mic.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]